is kyle pitts underrated all right here
we go
hey
i gotta have power can i try tackle him
get over here
tackle him right now
oh don't fundo
[Music]
welcome to underrated the only show
where we actually help professional
athletes improve their video game
ratings and today
we got kyle pitts
fourth pick in the draft stud out of
florida
and i know that he wants to be better
than he already is but we're gonna fix
those ratings today
kyle pitts you look like the real deal i
appreciate that what do you hope your
madden ratings are you were throwing the
ball medium throw accuracy
i'm going to be generous to get myself
70
26.
okay
that's crazy
look we know kyle pitts is the man in
real life but what about as a player in
madden let's go to our pro gamer yo boy
pizza if we go over to us throwing stats
this is disgusting this is hard for me
to look at i swear to you my grandmother
can throw better than kyle pitts and
madden 23 deep accuracy has this man
never thrown a football in his entire
life before i mean
this is disrespectful to this guy
kyle klimp clint kyle nice to meet you
nice to meet you
so you rank 18th among all tight ends
with medium throw accuracy rating of 26
but we want to see more
[Music]
let's all take a moment to recognize
that state farm offers great coverage
that fits your budget now let's see if
kyle pitts can make some footballs meet
our targets
so what we're gonna do is we got this
golf cart out here it's gonna keep
ripping back and forth 12 times
every time you hit it your madden rating
goes up too
every time you miss it the madden rating
goes down one
all right clint you ready
ready
[Music]
well pits
[Music]
let's go qb one
qb kyle
first throw
hey
number two
drops back
oh it was a little sidearm
oh
i got counts
look hey you put a hole in it kyle
don't break it y'all got to add power on
that yeah throw it you got to add power
it's a good point throw power
oh
and he overshot it
nope
that was close though that was close
[Music]
there it is
[Music]
if he hits the camera
[Music]
rules i think we got to give him that
one
come on it all comes down to this
[Music]
whoa
damn
so hold on clint
so buy your math
what did kyle pitch just do for his
intermediate throwing accuracy yeah
medium throw accuracy has gone up six
points so you're now going to be at 32.
nice
not bad throwing for a tight end
carrying the thing you're doing right
now did you fumble out at florida no no
no never not one not one what about high
school never
so what do you think you're carrying
this it should be about
83.
to 77.
yeah how do you feel about that
that's kind of shocking
shocking yeah i never remember kyle
pitts is shocked you can't tell because
he's wearing sunglasses
[Applause]
now whenever i'm looking for a tight end
in the nfl i'm looking for multiple
things number one can the player get
open and of course kyle pitts can can
they block and then number three because
they're bigger guys they're taking big
hits i need to see their carrying stat
up to make sure they can hold on to that
football for whenever they need to
carrying we have an obstacle course
clint let's walk them through
first up greased up ball yeah i said
we're gonna make it a little difficult
on you we're gonna grease the ball up so
it'll be very slippery like a rain game
heavy rain game heavy rain game okay
then you go through the ladder and then
what does he have to do with those
dinosaurs he's got a stiff arm the
dinosaurs while switching ball hand and
we want to see how the ball security is
on that transition then i see a box and
i see micah parsons so what's happening
in there yeah so mike parsons is
controlling a robot tackling dummy and
you're going to stand in the box for 20
to 30 seconds and he's going to try to
hit you with the dummy and you're going
to avoid it while hanging onto a greased
bowling ball sounds good after that he's
got to do some more jukes right he's
juking through a gauntlet there at the
end he's going to juke left right left
right switching ball hands yeah for the
way he's juking and the reason for this
is like i said he was always open you're
always open in college so we got to make
it hard on you since we don't have
anyone hitting you out here so we got we
got to see what you got all right hold
on how are you going to figure out how
much you're going to raise him up based
off of this obstacle course i'm just
looking out for kyle well listen i'm
gonna put a little bit of additional
pressure on you kyle listen to the two
guys directly in front of him on the
ratings he's at 77. rob gronkowski's a
78. george kittle's a 79.
holy you're not you're not just out
you're going to jump in the top 15 and
carry among tight ends with george
kittle and rob gronkowski
all right
that sounds good that sounds good
mike are you ready i'm ready he's ready
obstacle course ready three
two
one go
the greasy ball
he said ew
quick feet quick feet quick feet quick
feet quick feet okay stiff arm those
dinosaurs switch balls yes
how does oh yeah oh yeah
drop it
greased bowling ball
get in the box all right
get in there do that dance kyle do that
dance
oh don't fumble
you see he's calling you out micah
can i try to tackle him get over here
tackle him right now
[Music]
he got it pick him back up pick him back
up pick him back up we weren't expecting
that that's what happens on underrated
get over here make these cuts make these
cuts switch switch hands too left hand
first
yeah right there you go
oh that was quite the interesting drill
all right come over here
okay micah jumped on there seems like he
got a little pop yeah ball came out are
you weighing that into your rankings at
all yeah you know we have eyes so we're
gonna take everything into our
evaluation
but uh i mean overall i mean he did
really well with the stiff arms on the
crested football and he did well with
the jukes so
what are you doing about his rankings
carrying carry rating yeah just just
based on difficulty
of the drill and holding that ball you
can go up one point and carry you're
gonna be tied with rob gronkowski at a
78.
so you're now in the top 16 of all tied
ins with ball security okay
so
his throwing accuracy went up six
his carrying went out one i have one
question for my guy is kyle pitts
underrated
yes kyle pitts you are underrated and we
fixed that today
thank you i appreciate it are you
excited to see yourself at madden i
actually am i want to see how it looks
okay if he doesn't think he's attractive
enough can i fix that too in the game
give me a call okay
we got a guy now
go put a shirt on
you